drew barrymore finds happiness from her
beloved puppies during difficult times
very more recently called a quiz from
her husband will kopelman after nearly
four years of marriage he was the only
one to catch up with the 41 year old
actress at the ASPCA annual bird ball
Thursday where she was honored for her
work with animals I've been such a dog
lover my whole life and actually had
cats until I was 19 and then I started
adopting dog I've rescued nine different
dogs and foster dogs and currently have
a rescue dog named Douglas and life is
better with dogs and life is definitely
better with rescue dogs the Charlie's
Angels star shares two daughters with
her ex three year old olive and one year
old Frankie but admits her dogs have
helped her cope with life's hardships
listen there's a reason people cling to
their pet you know what I'm saying
though Barrymore doesn't speak directly
on her split she does have a positive
outlook on life thanks to her pups
animals have given me has been a rite of
passage and a humility and a purpose and
a kindness and a lack of cruelty I I
don't have it in my heart to be rude
mean cruel unkind to any person on the
planet let alone in animal
you